I get asked a lot what would I do if I
had 30,000 pounds to invest in property
what how exactly would I invest it so on
this video I'm gonna be explaining what
I would do with 30k okay so if I had
30,000 pounds in the world and that's
all I had to invest in property I
wouldn't want to invest in property I
think that if all I had in the world and
have any property investments or
anything I just a 30k I'd want to invest
at least some of it in myself educating
myself so that I can answer this
question properly if actually most in
property ha I think I would me knowing
what I know now for just a 30k I would
probably buy an apartment Birmingham
city centre that I could rent out on a
serviced accommodation basis I think
that would give the highest return on
investment I don't think you could beat
the returns of that type of deal so if I
had 30k I'd find a little apartment in
Birmingham I've just bought two of these
so I am in this position I haven't just
got 30k but I have got 30k and I am
investing thirty cages lots of times
doing lots of big deals land
developments castles but I'm also buying
these tops just I think that's what I
would probably do find a property a
hundred thousand pounds maybe in
Birmingham a little apartment one bed
permission to rent it service
accommodation permission with the lease
in the center boom rents out I've got
people that will manage it their returns
a lot 4050 percent ROI it's just insane
if you're watching this video there's no
magic this is the best thing to do I
don't think there's any magic answer I
think that you should invest in what you
know in fact I was chatting to Lord
Sugar about it I asked him a very
similar question as what you guys ask me
a lot I said if you if you had a hundred
grand Ward you investing we had a whole
conversation about it but one of the
things he said that was really important
was you should invest in what you know
if you know a lot about HMOs let's say
you've been experimenting and going on
training programs and learning all about
HMOs and you've got 30k I would probably
buy a cello with it that'd be a good
investment
maybe buy for bad four beds are really
good because five beds you need a
license for the new changes coming in
and stuff you need a license so the
difference between four and five bed is
our license so if you're going to get a
license anyway sometimes I think you
maze with up to six if it's more than
six you need planning
real simple if you have 30 grand and
that's it your best bet will probably to
be buying a full bed in a cheap area
city center maybe somewhere like
Liverpool Walsall what's also good
what's right in that sheet you could do
Bradford just I'd find a cheap area
where I knew that there was a high
demand
there was no article for for bed HMO buy
it for like 80 90 grand your 30 grands
gonna get swallowed up in that one deal
because deposit could be 20 grand but
then you've got your furniture I
probably if I had only 30 grand at least
my furniture to save putting down much
money rent for rooms out fetch rent
about 1,400 pounds a month of course
you're gonna have to pay expenses and
that but you could easily birth of seven
hundred pound a month seven hundred
pound a month cash flow investing 30
grand in not bad especially when the
obstacle falls gonna come in the
property's gonna shoot up rents are
going up so that'll probably be the
second thing that I would do the third
thing that I would do if I was
absolutely brand spanking new to
property and a 30 grand I don't know
anything about service accommodation I
didn't know anything about HMOs I didn't
have any mentors and was too tight to
pay for mentor and good audience Lee if
you've got 30 grams and that's it you
could put it into property but I mean
I'm not saying she put the whole 30
grand but at least put 10% at least put
10% into educating yourself mentor books
CDs whatever it's an argument or you
ain't gonna be able to do it 10% but
find someone the world but the third
thing that I might do is I might 30
grand just go and buy a sing all that
property or a couple because if they're
very cheap fifty grand properties which
you can find in many parts of the
country
you only need 15 grand you could buy a
couple of single necks or just one sing
all that property you know even if it's
just giving you an income of four or
five hundred pound a month still you're
on the property ladder
you've got some income coming in its
gonna help you when going to buy some
more some bigger development properties
or or even HMOs potentially and then
just assess it but whatever you do when
you start a new investor first 30 grand
assess it do a spreadsheet and stuff and
work out what return on investment you
get in last thing you can do with the 30
grand is buy a house to live in
because how she living is not an asset
because the definition of an asset is
something that puts money in your pocket
every single month know the worst thing
you could do worse than that would be
just spending it on stuff or spending on
stuff that disappears just don't I mean
geez please don't do that invest in
something home answers the question if
you up thirty thousand pounds in the
back right now hopefully you've got more
if you had 30,000 pounds and that was it
what would you do with it would you
invest in an HMO service accommodation
and would you buy a couple single x or a
single net or would you invest it in
yourself comment your thoughts below on
this video
also don't forget to share subscribe
like I really appreciate that love you
forever see you next time thank you so
much for watching if you benefit just on
that video please do share it with your
family and friends for more videos like
it you can watch right here and if you'd
like to spend two days with me at the
property investors crash course watch
this video see what happens but whatever
you do don't forget to subscribe right
here and I'll see you next time